A: The second graders are full of
fun things to do,
but before that, there's the final exam.
I'm being told it's a
prickly view of human society Well, let's do it, don't think you're living alone
Come on, this teacher made a group of 3 people who sorted out the rides with average grades
Each team cooperated and gave birth to 8  Compete
and aim for the top with countermeasures We will hold a game with
one data I want to say I think
it's an Omuro Glider game or an entertainment
Kotoko: I forgot how to ask questions
Why do I have to pretend to study with those two at this important time at the end of the semester?
Considering their friendship, it didn't seem like
you had any other friends, and although
Check didn't grow up very well, I wanted to point out that they weren't my friends, but then I felt
like I really had no friends, and was
lonely.